شكرا لكريم اذا التغطيه مستمره معكم على
شاشه العربيه الرئيس الامريكيه السابق دون
الترامب يصل الى محكمه ميامي لبدء اجراءات
المحاكمه الرئيس ترامب وفي تغريدته على
منصه روث سوشل قال فيها بانه في طريقه
للمحكمه فلنجعل امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى
طبعا هذا الشعار الذي دائما ما يتخذه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب خصوصا في
الانتخابات السابقه دائما كان يتحدث عن
جعل امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى وكنا تبعنا
معكم صور لمغادره موكب الرئيس دونالد
ترامب من منتجعه الى مقر المحكمه في ميامي
طبعا ننقل لكم اذا هذه الصور والمشاهد
مباشره على شاشه العربيه جديد المعلومات
التي تاتينا فيما يتعلق ماذا يحدث عندما
يصل ترمت الى المحكمه اذا ما ان نتحدث
تباعا وتسلسلا عن جديد الاخبار بمجرد دخول
اذا ترامب المبنى سيتم وضعه قيد الاعتقال
وايضا من المتوقع ان يتخذ نواب المرسلات
بصمات ترامب الكترونيا هنا نتحدث عن
البروتوكول والاجراءات المتعلقه بهذه
المحاكمه لكن ليس من المتوقع ان ياخذوا
صوره شخصيه للرئيس السابق طبعا هناك
اختلافات عن اجراءات هذه المحكمه عما جرى
في نيويورك طبعا في السابق جراء تهم
السابقه فيما يتعلق بممثله الافلام
الاباحيه سومي دانييل والدفع لها مقابل
شراء صمتها في انتخابات عام 2016 على كل
حال التغطيه مستمره معكم وايضا سيكون معنا
من امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي حسين
الطوب مراسل العربيه حسين قال بالتاكيد
اليوم وخصوصا الاجواء حتى هذه اللحظات في
اوجها ضعنا في صوره الوضع حيث انت تحسن
تحيه لك نادينا بالفعل مع الاعلان عن وصول
الى هذه المحكمه عدد المناصرين له ازداد
بشكل كبير انا الان في وسطهم شعارات مؤيده
لترامب والمناصريه
يقولون لا يريدون
هؤلاء كما كانت الشرطه قالت لهم قد يصلون
عددهم الى ما بين 5000 الى 50,000 وهي
مستعده للتعامل مع هذا
العدد اذا اضطرت لذلك طبعا هناك وجود امني
مكثف في هذه المنطقه
يعتقدون ترامب وصله من الجهه المقابله
لهذه المحكمه هناك باب اخر من الجهه
المقابله هناك كما قلنا الحضور امني كثير
نسمعك من كثره هذه الهتافات لانصار الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب في محيط المحكمه
سنحاول ان نفهم عليك قدر الامكان فيما
يتعلق بمجريات المحكمه اليوم حسين فيما
يتعلق بالاجراءات الامنيه التي تحدثت عنها
في محيط المحكمه
ووسط التوقعات بان يصل عدد الانصار الرئيس
السابق ل50,000 هل حصلت اي تجاوزات اي
خروقات مناوشات مع الشرطه
حتى الان في المكان المتواجد في محول
المحكمه لم نرى اي تجوزات او اي اصطدام مع
الشرطه ما جرى منذ تقريبا ثلاث ساعات كان
هناك الشرطه شكت
[موسيقى]
جهاز تلفزيوني كان موضوع بطريقه معينه
قامت بازالته طلبت منا الابتعاد عن المكان
خوفا عن حفاظا على سلامتنا كما قالت لنا
من غير ذلك لم يكن هناك صدمات لنعرف الان
اذا كان العدد وصل الى تجاوز الخمسه الاف
ام لا ولكن الشرطه انقرض انها مستعده
للتعامل مع اي اعداد كانت كان هناك تخوف
في الحقيقه من حدوث اعمال نسيمه مع دعوات
من الطيار اليميني في الحزب الجمهوري
للتجمهر والدفاع بعضهم قال ان نحن الان في
حاله حرب حتى ذكر هذه الكلمه ما خلق خلق
لدى
اجهزه الشرطه في ميامي وايضا لدى عمده
الذي طلبه النفس وطالب المتظاهرين بان
يتظاهروا حتى بعض الجمهوريين حذر ان هذه
الدعوات العبقه تقول وهنا المفارقه قد
تكون فخ
تنصبه لهم وزاره العدل على حسب تعبيره من
اجل اعتقال اكبر عدد من انصاري بدل اعتقال
ترامب هذا كان تحذير من احد النواب
الجمهوريين في المجلس النواب ولكن ابي حتى
الان حتى هذه اللحظه منذ ساعات الصباح
الموجود هنا منذ التسعه صباحا وحتى الان
الساعه الثانيه ظهرا لم نشاهد اي اصطدام
بل كان هناك تظاهرات سلميه هناك شعارات
تهدف من اجل ترامب ضد بايدن بالاسبانيه
وبالانجليزيه حتى هناك عدد كبير من
اللاتينيين الامريكيين الذين اتوا يؤيدون
التراب وحتى لاحظنا وجود عدد من
الامريكيين من اصول الافريقيه ايضا كانوا
يقولون بلاك هم سود مع ترامب هذا ما
سمعناهم يقولونه وهذه الاجواء كما تسمعيها
نادين حولي الان اتمنى نتحدث عن عن كما
قلنا العدد الاكبر من الموجودين هم من
انصار ترامب لم الاحظ عدد من الانصار بيضا
كثيرا الوضع يختلف عن ما كانت عليه في
نيويورك هذه ولايه تميل الى الجمهوريين
لذلك كان متوقع عن حضور جمهوري اكبرم
وبالتاكيد حيث منتجع ترامب الرئيسي ومقر
اقامته الان قبل ان يتجه وتوجه الى مقر
محكمه ميامي لبدء اجراءات المحاكمه اذا
نشير الى مشاهدي العربيه بان الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب سيمثل بعد قليل امام
المحكمه في ميامي حيث ننقل لكم هذه الصور
بقضيه الوثائق السريه
حسين حتى نتضعنا في الصوره اليوم فيما
يتعلق بمساله اجراءات وسير المحاكمه ما
المنتظر وماذا نتوقع في تسلسل المحاكمه
اليوم
نادين هناك اكثر من سيناريوه سينا مفتوحه
على جميع الاحتمالات كما قرانا في وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه لكن السيناريو الاغلب
الذي يتم الحديث عنه الان لانه سيكون
تكرار لما حدث في نيويورك عندما عندما وصل
ترامب فدخل الى الى المحكمه اي من
المستبعد ان تؤخذ له صوره ليس مستحيل يعني
امر مستبعد يمكن ولكن مستبعد قد تؤخذ له
بصمات الكترونيا وليس عبر الحبر كي لا
يستخدم مهامه في دعايه بانه مضطهد سياسيا
ستطلع على الاتهامات سيقول بانه غير مذنب
من المراجعه ليتم اطلاق صراحه بكفاله وان
يعود بعد ذلك الى منتجعه في نيوجيرسي شمال
الولايات المتحده هناك سيلقي خطاب تقريبا
على الساعه الثامنه والربع بتوقيت الساحل
الشرقي الى امريكا هذا السيناريو هو يشابه
السيناريو الذي في او حدث بده شهرين
عامه معروفه لذلك هو بحاجه لياخذ لها صوره
المنشار وايضا بانه رئيس يعني له تعاملات
قد تكون
متميزه لانه شخصيه معروفه واحتراما لمنصب
الرئاسه كما كان يقول العديد من المحرمين
سابقا بنا منصب الرئاسه له احترام سيتم
التعامل معه على هذا الاساس طيب حسين فقط
اذا ما قارنا بالاتهام الذي وجه للرئيس
السابق فيما يتعلق بمحاكمه نيويورك هل
يختلف الوضع اليوم يعني لن نرى ترامب وهو
يدخل وهو يغادر ولا اي اثر لوجوده كشخص
فيما يتعلق بسير المحكمه
بحسب الترجيحات هو سيدخل من الى
موقف تحت الارض لذلك من المستبعد ان
نشاهده كما شاهدناه عندما دخل الى المحكمه
في نيويورك من خلال احد انبوبتها الرئيسيه
على الشارع هنا الموقف سيكون تحت الارض
وهناك النفق سيدخل منه لذلك من المستبعد
ان نشاهده
المحكمه هذه التهمه التي وجهت لها في سبيل
المقارنه هي اخطر بكثير من التهم السابقه
في نيويورك هذه تهم جديه قد يصل الامر الى
سجنه
حتى
الديمقراطيين بعض الديمقراطيين مثل زعيم
الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه الشيوخ قال بان تهم
البراك ليست لها مصداقيه كبيره هي في
النهايه كانت بانه ارتكب جنح جنح وليست
جنايه كان يحاولون ان يربطوها بتزوير سجل
تجاري هذه التهم الان هي تهم لها علاقه
بقانون التجسس تهم مؤامره
شهاده زور هذه كما يقول المحللون وحتى من
الجمهوريين انفسهم لانها اكثر خطوره من
التهم التي وجهت له في في نيويورك والتي
قال الكثير من المؤيدين والمعارضين بانها
تهم ضعيفه
وانتقد انه
فرصه ليكون لديه خبره في كيفيه التعامل مع
الموضوع لهذا السبب منظر الى ما يجري الان
على انه اكثر خطوره مما هو مما كان عليه
في نيويورك وهنا يجب ان نذكر بان هناك
ايضا تحقيقان اخران في جورجيا
بحجه ان ترامب يزعم بانه تدخل لقلب
النتائج الانتخابات عام 2020 وايضا
تحقيق بشان
تورته المزعوم باحداث السادس من يناير عام
2021 حسين بالتاكيد ستبقى معنا في سياق
هذه التغطيه في التاسعه هذا المساء على
شاشه العربيه حيث سيمثل الرئيس السابق تون
الترامب بعد قليل امام المحكمه في ميامي
حيث وصل موكب الرئيس ترامب الى محكمه
ميامي لبدء اجراءات المحاكمه بتهم تتعلق
بتعامله مع وثائق سريه بعد مغادرته البيت
الابيض مازلنا ننقل لكم هذه الصور من
ميامي وايضا مع ضيوف العربيه الكرام نذهب
الان الى واشنطن
عبر زوم الدكتور ريتشر بيرس استاذ القانون
في جامعه جورج واشنطن دكتور ريتشرد مرحبا
بك معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه نتحدث معك
الان باللغه القانونيه فيما يتعلق بالتهم
الموجهه لرئيس السابق دونا دونالد ترامب
بالنظر لهذه التهم دكتور ريتشرد هل يمكن
ان ينجو ترامب منها
اذا ما كانوا قد حققوا نجاحا في اثبات
الجرائم التي زعم بها فقد ينجح
لا يتعرض الى اي عقوبات
طيب حتى نفهم اصل المشكله واساس المشكله
قانونيا هل لدى الرئيس الامريكي الحق
بالاحتفاظ بوثائق سريه بعد ترك منصبه رفع
السريه عنها والتعامل معها كيفما يشاء
واينما يشاء
هذا بكل تاكيد انتهاك للقانون
وهذا وكما تعلمون فان لائحه الاتهام تضم
37 اتهام بما في ذلك انتهاك قانون التجسس
الذي يعود لسبعينيات القرن الماضي وهذا
القانون يعاقب اي شخص حتى لو كان نائبا
للرئيس
وتركز العقوبه على
اخفاء تلك المستندات السريه
طب دكتور ريتشارد هذه المره الدعوه رفعت
من وزاره العدل عكس قضيه نيويورك يعني
رفعت من المدعيه العامه للولايه حينها ما
المختلف وماذا يعني ذلك الان قانونيا
المشاهدين
لم اسمع الجزء الاخير من السؤال ماذا يعني
ذلك اليوم ما المختلف عندما نتحدث عن
محاكمه موجهه من رفعت من وزاره العدل
مباشره في مقابل محاكمه نيويورك من قبل
المدعيه العامه للولايه حينها
هذه المحاكمه جديه وخطيره اكثر بكثير فنحن
فالاشاره هنا الى جرائم فيدراليه وليست
جرائم على مستوى الولايه وهي جرائم خطره
للغايه
نظريه
القضايا الموجهه ضد الرئيس السابق ترامب
قد تحمل
عقوبات
نظرا لجديتها
لكن تلك التي كانت على مستوى الولايه فلم
تكن بنفس مستوى الخطوره
ان كانت خطره وخطيره جدا قانونيا كيف يمكن
ذلك
اذا ما استطاعوا ان يثبتوا دون ادنى شك
بانه
قد اتخذ اجراءات دفعت لتوجيه هذه
الاتهامات فلا اعتقد انه يمتلك اي دفع وكل
ما يستطيع ان يقوله هو ان يقوم بتاجيل
المحاكمه والمماطله بها
والامر سوف يبقى علينا ان ننتظر لنرى اذا
كيف سوف تنتقل الى محاكمه رسميه طيب اذا
ما سبقنا سيناريوهات دكتور ريتشرد وقرانا
المستقبل مثلا في حال ادانه الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب هل يسجن فورا
هذا القرار سوف يكون متروكا للقاضي
ومن المحتمل انه قد يسمح لبعض المدعى
عليهم ان يبقوا خارج السجن اذا ما كانوا
قد نفد اذا ما كان قد نفد منهم حقوق الطعن
او يمكنهم البقاء خارج خارج السجن الى حين
الانتهاء من كافه الحقوق التي يمتلكونها
في تقديم الطعونات طيب دكتور في حال تمت
ادانته هو تم سجنه فعلا هل من مده محدده
[موسيقى]
كل من هذه هي الجرائم 37 بما في ذلك
انتهاك قانون التجسس
يعاقب عليها بعشر سنوات من السجن قد نتحدث
عن ثلاث عن 340 سنه كحد اقصى لتلك
الانتهاكات
وهناك بعض الجرائم الاخرى ايضا التي يعاقب
عليها بفترات مختلفه فسجن بصرف النظر عن
تفاصيل المده الزمنيه التي قد يعاقب عليها
لكن
العقاب سوف يكون اطول مما قد يعيشه اترم
في حياته
ونحن ننقل لكم هذه الصور اتمنى ان تبقى
معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه ونتابع معكم
جديد التطورات والجديد الصور التي تردنا
من امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي وفي
محيطها حيث يتجمع انصار الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب ويتجمعوا ايدوه وهم يهتفون
حتى ان مراسل العربيه في ميامي حسين التوت
كان اكد بان هناك اناسا اتوا من اكثر من
منطقه ومن عرقيات مختلفه
ورفعوا الشعرات وهتافات مؤيده للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب حيث من المقرر ان
يمثل بعد قليل في المحكمه الفيدراليه في
ميامي جراء التهم المتوجهه الينا نتحدث عن
سبع وثلاثين تهمه طبعا هذه هي صور كما
نتابع معكم هذه الصور اللافته هنا صوره
الرئيس السابق دونالد تر عندما غادر
منتجعه في ملالاجو حيث هو يشاهد الان في
هذه السياره قبل ان يغادر موكبه الى الى
المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي لبدء اجراءات
المحاكمه ما زلنا ننقل لكم هذه الصور نذهب
مره اخرى الى ضيفنا ضيفنا دكتور ريتشارد
لنتحدث معه بالقانون فيما يتعلق باجراءات
هذه المحاكمه دكتور ريتشارد حتى نفهم اكثر
عندما نتحدث عن 37 تهمه في حال مثلا تمت
ادانته ببعض من التهم وتم التبرئته في
التهم الاخرى كيف سيكون معالجه المساله
قانونيا معه فيما يتعلق بالحكم
اذا ما تمت ادانته ببعض التهم
وتبرئته بتهم الاخرى فهذه سوف تكون مساله
تتعلق بكل جريمه بحد ذاتها
والتفاصيل قد لا تكون مهمه
ومن غير المرجح انه سوف يعيش لفتره كافيه
اذا ما تمت ادانته وتم زجه بالسجن
وحتى لو كان قد تمت ادانته بثلاثه او
اربعه من تلك التهم فقط
طب دكتور ريتشارد تتحدث وكان هذه التهم
ستدين فعلا في المستقبل القريب انطلاقا من
ماذا هل احتماليه نجاه ترامب قانونيه من
هذه الطعم الموجهه اليه قليله ضئيله
اعتقد ان الناحيه المثيره للاهتمامه في
هذه القضيه ان فرصه قد لا تكون قويه وجيده
فهناك ادله قويه حسب ما يبدو ضده لكن من
الصعب ان يتم
تقديم
ادانا جنائيه في النظام الامريكي لان
الامر يقتضي بتقديم
القضاه لاثباته بان الشخص قد قام بشكل لا
يدفع لا يدع اي مجال للشك باقترافي تلك
الجرائم ونعلم ان ان الناس قد صوتوا
للرئيس ترامب في السابق هو من المؤكد
بانهم قد لا يصدقون بانه قد ارتكبت تلك
الجرائم فهناك تحدي كبير مات امام النيابه
العامه وفي ظل انواع الفهم المختلفه
اذا يخضع ترامب لتحقيق في 37 تهمه جنائيه
منها ما يتعلق بعرقله العداله ومنها ما
يتعلق باسرار نوويه خطيره اذا يخضع فيها
للتحقيق في سبع وثلاثين تهمه جنائيه منها
ما يتعلق بعرقله العداله ومنها ما يتعلق
باسرار نوويه خطيره شرطه ميامي قالت انها
جاهزه للتعامل مع الحشود الكبيره
والاحتجاجات في جلسه الاستماع لترامب الذي
يواجه الاتهامات القضائيه للمره الثانيه
خلال شهرين لكن هذه المره على مستوى
الفيدرالي فقد اعلنت وزاره العدل
الامريكيه الجمعه توجيعه توجيها 37 اتهام
له في قضيه ارشيف في البيت الابيض لكن لدى
ترامب بريق امل فمن سيتراس المحكمه وتدير
متلا وامامها اليوم هي القاضيه ايلين
كانون والتي عينها ترامب قبل ثلاثه اعوام
في المحكمه الفيدراليه للمنطقه الجنوبيه
من فلوريدا والم عروفه بقرب هذا الحزب
الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
اذا نذكر ونشير الى هذا العاج الذي ترونه
اسفل الشاشه امامكم في جديد المعلومات
والاقبال تاتينا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذه سي ان ان تتحدث عن ان
الرئيس السابق ترامب الان رهن الاعتقال
بقضيه الوفائق السريه سنناقش هذه النقطه
مع الدكتور ريتشارد بيرس استاذ القانون في
جامعه جورج واشنطن دكتور ريتشرد مرحبا بك
معنا مجددا في سياق هذه التغطيه حتى نفهم
اكثر عندما تقول بان الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب الان
رهن الاعتقال بقضيه الوثائق السريه هل هذا
يعني بان الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
معتقل تماما كما اي مثلا مدان بنفس
الطريقه قد يعامل معامله مدان بجرائم
ليست تماما لهذا الحد فهو يخضع
لنظريه قرينه البراءه الى حين اثبات عكس
ذلك
ومن غير المرجح تماما بانهم سوف يضعون اي
قيد من قيود
[موسيقى]
معاملته
معتقل وسوف يحترمون
سلوكه في نفس الوقت سوف يذكرونه بانه لا
يسمح له التواصل مع اي من الشهود او
محاوله اتواصل في قضايا جنائيه
ذات ابعاد خطيرا
واما اذا ما تمت ادانته
اما اذا ما تمت ما تمت براءته فسوف يحق له
التصرف بالطريقه التي يحلو لها به
عن القاضيه التي عينها الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب ايلين كانون وهي تدير مثلها
امام المحكمه الفيدراليه اليوم معروفه
بقربها من الحزب الجمهوري كل هذه المعطيات
المتعلقه بقاضيه المحكمه الفيدراليه اليوم
هل يمكن ان تندي بشيء ما حول سير المحاكمه
قانونيا
لم يؤثر وجودها على نتائج
المثول امام المحكمه لكن على القضاه
في هذه المحكمه سوف عليهم ان
انظروا احكامهم اخذين في الاعتبار بعض
المشاعر الخاصه وعلى القاضي التزام ان
يقرر ما هي الادله المتاحه او المتوفره
ومن ثم سوف يقوم باحاله الامر الى هيئه
المحلفين وما هي القواعد التي يجب تطبيقها
في القضيه لكن للقاضي صلاحيات واسعه فيما
يتعلق في قضايا من هذا النوع
لسماحي للمسائل الاجرائيه ان تطبق بصوره
صحيحه
هذه التغطيه اذهب الان الى مديره مكتب
العربيه في واشنطن ناديه بلبيسي ناديه
مرحبا بك معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه ابرز
العناوين هذا اليوم التي تاتينا من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وتحديدا من
ولايه فلوريدا
اهم عنوان نادين هو سابقه تاريخيه بالفعل
ان نرى رئيس للولايات المتحده رئيس سابق
يواجه القضاء والان كما تتحدث كل المحطات
الامريكيه هو رهن الاعتقال هذا هو العنوان
الاساسي بان رئيس ترامب هو رهن الاعتقال
هذا لا يعني بانه سيبقى في داخل المحكمه
او انه سيذهب الى السجن لكن كما تعرفين
سيتم ربما تلاء كل التهم 37 في داخل
المحكمه سيكون هناك اجراءات باخذ اسمه رقم
مكان اقامته الى اخره كل المعلومات التي
تقوم المحكمه باجراء روتيني ضد اي شخص
متهم بعد ذلك طبعا كما نعرف الرئيس ترامب
سيقول بانه غير مذنب لكل التهم الموجهه
ضده
ومجرد اطلاق صلاحيه بعد المثول امام
القاضي سيستقل طائراته الخاصه
سيعود الى نيوجيرسي الى بادمان وهو
المنتجع او ملعب الجولف التابع للرئيس
وسيلتقي الليله بالتحديد مع مؤيديه
وانصاره الذين
سيجتمعون لتقديم الدعم مالي له وبالتالي
سنسمع الليله من الرئيس ربما نفس الخطاب
السياسي بانه ضحيه بان هناك دوله عميقه
بان هناك ازدواجيه من معايير بان رئيس
بايدن لم يقدم الى المحاكمه ولا ايضا هنري
كلينتون وغيرهم لكن اهم عنوان هو باننا
مره اخرى نتحدث عن رئيس سابق يواجه القضاء
مرتين في اقل من يعني اشهر بضعه اشهر
رايناه في نيويورك ورايناه الان في ميامي
لكن تهم ميامي ومثل امام المحكمه
الفيدراليه والاكثر خطوره نادين بكل اسباب
التي نتحدث عليها عنها طوال هذه الايام
وهي انه متهم بحيازه وثائق سريه تتعلق
بالامن القومي الامريكي ناديه انت دائما
السباقه في النقل المعلومات التي تاتينا
من البيت الابيض هل صدرت اي تصريحات
تعليقات جديده من البيت الابيض الذي يطمع
الرئيس السابق بالعوده اليه مره اخرى رغم
كل هذه العراقيل
عندنا شك لكن البيت الابيض في العاده
يلتزم الصمت لانه في اي موضوع قانوني او
قضائي لا يستطيع ان يتدخل رغم ان رئيس
ترامب طبعا يوظف بانه هذه الاداره هي
اداره ديمقراطيه يوظف هذا الاتهام لصالح
يبانوب بالفعل ضحيه وبان هناك اتصال ما
بين البيت الابيض وما بين وزير العدل لكن
البيت الابيض ينئي بنفسه عن اي تصريحات
على الاطلاق حتى بالامس انا كنت موجوده في
الاجازه الصحفي حاولنا اكثر من مره مع جون
كاربي او مع كريم جانبير متحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض الجميع يعيد يعني مهما
حاولتي تسالي السؤال هي الاجابه نفسها
باننا لا نستطيع ان نعلق على قضيه تجري
حاليا وهي قضيه جنائيه هناك محاكم هناك
تحقيق وبالتالي لا نستطيع ان نتدخل لكن
بدون ادنى شك بانه البيت الابيض يرى بانه
هذا
سيؤثر على الحملات الانتخابيه اها
للجمهوريين وعلى الترشح بالنسبه للرئيس
ترامب وعلى فرصي حتى بالوصول الى فوزي
بترشح الحزب الجمهوري لنرى ماذا سيحدث بعد
ذلك وهل سيستطيع الرئيس من خلال فريق
الدفاع
بالفعل ان يؤخر هذه المحاكمه ان يدافع عن
نفسه وبالتالي يسقط بعض التهم وخصوصا وان
ايلين كانون هذه القاضيه التي عينها ترامب
شخصيا ليست هي ايضا جمهوريه او مواليه
لجمهوريه لكنها معينه من الرئيس ترامب
والبعض يرى بانها قد تكون غير ملائمه لان
تكون هي القاضيه لانه ربما تكون منحازه
رغم ان كل القضاه يقسمون قسما بغض النظر
عن دماء انتماءاتهم السياسيه بان يكون
الولاء فقط للقضاء والقانون وليس لاي شخص
او رئيس طيب ناديه طالما تحدثتي عن
القاضيه التي عينها ترامب اصلا هذه المره
الدعوات رفعت من وزاره العدل عكس قضيه
نيويورك التي رفعتها المدعيه العامه
للولايه كيف يمكن التفرقه وما المختلف
اليوم في المحاكمتين
المحكمه الفيدراليه الجديه لانه كما ذكرتي
هناك تحقيق من وزاره العدل لانه اذا رجعنا
الى بدايه القضيه بانه كان هناك علم بان
رئيس ترامب احتفظ بوثائق سريه البعض البعض
هذه الوثائق صنفت بانها سريه للغايه تتعلق
باسرار الاتفاق النووي او القدره النوويه
لايران قدره الدفاعيه للولايات المتحده
ودول حليفه اخرى وبالتالي عندما تم تعيين
محقق خاص من وزاره العدل هذا المحقق بدا
بجمع الادله وكان هناك هيئه محلفين قرروا
بانه الادله كافيه لتوجيه اتهام وهذا هو
ربما الاجراء القانوني وبالتالي وزاره
العدل لم حتى تريد ان تكون المحكمه في
واشنطن لانها لا تريد ان تعطي انطباع بانه
هناك تسييس للقضيه وكما تعرفين مقاطعه
واشنطن وهي العاصمه معظمها باغلبها يعني
تصوت للديمقراطيين وعند انتقاء هيئه
المحلفين سيكون عدد كبير منهم من
الديمقراطيين رغم انه يجب ان لا يكون
لديهم انتماء يعني نوعا ما لكن ايضا في
لذا تم نقل المحكمه الى ميامي لذا ايضا في
ميامي هناك حديث على انه اختيار هيئه
المحلفين قد يكون عدد كبير منهم من مؤيدين
الرئيس ترامب وبالتالي ندخل في تسييس
القضيه التي يتحدث عنها الرئيس رغم انها
البعض يرى عن خبراء القانونيين يروا بانه
لا علاقه لها بالسياسه وبالفعل كان هناك
اتهام بانه ليس فقط بحيازه هذه الوثائق
السريه لكن بعرقله مجرى العداله وهي احد
التهم الموجهه لترامب كما تعرفين نادين
لانه رفضت التعاون مع المؤسسات الامنيه
والفدراليه وبالتالي اضطرت وزاره العدل
الى الحصول على تخويل بارسال عناصر من
الاف بي اي لمداهمه منزلي ومصادره كل هذه
الوثائق والبعض يرى بانه حتى بعد ذلك
ترامب احتفظ بوثائق اخرى وكما ناقد نفسه
لم ينزع عنها السريه بعد احتفاظ بها رغم
كل هذه التهم ناديه صوره امامنا هناك
انصار هناك داعمون ومؤيدون للرئيس ترامب
اذا ما تحدثنا عن الراي العام الامريكي
سواء جمهوريين او ديمقراطيين كيف هو كيف
ينظرون الترامب اليوم
كان يسبب حاله من الانقسام بين الامريكيين
وهناك ايضا شريحه وفيه مخلصه له تبقى معه
حتى النهايه حتى لو قدم امام عشر محاكم
وكان هناك حتى تهم بالقتل اذا اردت هؤلاء
الاشخاص يؤمنون بان الرئيس ضحيه والرئيس
استطاع ان يقنعهم بشكل كبير بان هذه
الاتهامات ليست ضده بل ضدهم بانه يقف امام
المحاكم ليس بوحده بل يدافع عنهم وبالتالي
هو يربط نفسه مع هذه الشريحه التي تمثل
30% من الحزب الجمهوري لكن هذه الشريحه
غير كافيه بالنسبه له للفوز بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه لكن بالنسبه لحاله الانقسام
موجوده الان استطلاعات الراي تقول بانه
يعني بدايه هذه الازمه بانه معظم
الامريكيين لا يريدون الرئيس ترامب ان
يترشح لزعامه الحزب الجمهوري ولا الرئيس
بايدن للح الديمقراطي وبالتالي يريدون ان
يروا وجوه جديده ليس فقط بسبب مشاكل ترامب
القانونيه وكل هذه الملاحقات وطريقته طبعا
بالحديث عن حاله الانقسام التي تسود
البلاد لكن ايضا تقدمهم بالعمر سواء كان
الرئيس بايدن او الرئيس ترامب شكرا لك
ناديه بلبيسي مديره مكتب العربيه في
واشنطن والتغطيه مستمره على العربيه نذهب
معكم الى هذا التقرير ومتابعه ردود
الافعال حول محاكمه رئيس سابق دونالد
ترامب اليوم
[موسيقى]
رحلات ترامب تعددت قبل الوصول الى محطه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه العامه المقبل غير ان
رحلته الابرز التي تشوبها الكثير من
المخاطر تلك التي يخوضها في مواجهه القضاء
الرئيس الاكثر اثاره للجدل في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده بين مدافعين عنه
ومنتقدين له ابرز ردود الافعال اتخذت
اتجاهين متعاكسين حد الاصطدام والمواجهه
حلفاء ترامب يستميتون في الدفاع عنه
ويستنكرون ما سموها ملاحقات سياسيه
محاميته اكدت ان الترامب كل الحق في
الاحتفاظ بوثائق بعد ان رفعت عنها السريه
النائب الجمهوري جيم جوردان كرر ان
المحاكمه من تدبير معسكر الرئيس
الديمقراطي جو بايدن رغم ان لائحه الاتهام
تبنتها هيئه محلفين كبرى من المواطنين في
فلوريدا رئيس بلديه ميامي الجمهور فرانسيس
سواريز عبر عن امله في ان تمر الامور
بسلام
من الناس الى ان يكونوا مسالمين في اظهار
مشاعرهم النائب عن الوزيانز طلب من انصاره
ربط حزام الامان للانطلاق اما من ولايه
اريزونا فقد غرد قائلا لقد وصلنا الان الى
مرحله الحرب العين بالعين في المقابل قال
وزير العدل السابق بالبار الذي بات ينتقد
ترامب بعد ان عمل معه ان لائحه الاتهام
مفصله للغايه بار اعتبر مساله ان الرئيس
لديه السلطه الكامله لتصنيف اي وثقه على
انها شخصيه فكره سخيفه من جهته حاكم ولايه
نيوجيرسي السابق انتقد ترامب واصفا اياه
بانه رجل غاضب وانتقامي يتحمل مسؤوليه دفع
الامه الى لحظه اخرى مثيره للانقسام بشكل
غير عادي وفق تعبيره في اثناء ذلك البيت
الابيض يواصل رفض التعليق على القضيه في
حين يشير ديمقراطيون الى ان فوز ترامب
بالرئاسه
قد يكون امله الوحيد لتجنب السجن بلال
البشتين العربيه
نذهب الان الى واشنطن هناك حسين عبد
الحسين الباحث في مؤسسه دفاع عن
الديمقراطيات استاذ حسين مرحبا بك معنا في
هذه التغطيه على العربيه البيان الاتهامي
يسخر بحق ترامب فيما يتعلق باكثر من تهمه
بقضيه الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ بها بعد
انتهاء ولايته لكنه يخلو من عنصر هام وهو
دوافع الرئيس الامريكي بالتالي اسالك
لماذا برايك احتفظ ترامب هذه الوثائق ورفض
تسليمها
مساء الخير طبعا هذه ليست يعني جريمه قتل
الجريمه عاده تكون
خلفها دوافع ولكن هذه اجراءات ومن غير
المفهوم
السبب الذي دفع ترامب للاحتفاظ بهذه
الوسائل طبعا حسب الادعاء الادعاء مبني
على قانون مكافحه التجسس وهذا يعني انه
ترامب احتفظ بهذه الوثائق بدافع التجسس
ربما
لابتزاز عالميين ربما يعني نيل حظوه لدى
زعماء عالميه لا نعرف فعليا السبب الفعلي
ولكن السبب الابرز حتى الان يبدو ما ورد
في ناحيه التجسس طيب استاذ حسين هل هناك
من
عوده ترامب الى البيت الابيض مره اخرى
لهذا توضع العراقيل في طريقه اليوم
يعني اعتقد انه هناك منافسه طبعا يعني
الديمقراطيون لا يريدون عوده يريدون فوز
بايدن بولايه ثانيه هذا واضح
جزء من الجمهوريين ياملون ان يكون المرشح
الجمهوري مرشحا اخرا غير ترامب وهذا واضح
ايضا ولكن هل هناك يعني ما هي نسبه
التفكير السياسي او ما هي نسبه المواجهات
السياسيه التي تدخل في حسابات وزاره العدل
الامريكيه وفي حسابات المسار القضائي انا
لا اراها كثيرا في الوقت الحالي ولكن طبعا
قادم الايام سيظهر لنا ما هي الدوافع لدى
لدى وزاره العدل هل كانت فعليا تطبيق
القانون وحده ام كان هناك دوافع سياسيه
استاذ محاميه ترامب اعتبرت بانه ضمن حقوقه
الاحتفاظ
بمستندات بعد مغادرته البيت الابيض بصفتها
كما وصفتها تذكره شخصيه او وثائق رفعت
عنها السريه كيف تقيم هذا الكلام قانونيا
لا افهم ما هي الدوافع او النظريه
القانونيه التي يتحدث يتم الحديث عنها لكن
من حق الرئيس ان يحتفظ بمسندات ان رفعت
عنها السريه واذا ما كان هذا الامر قد حدث
فهناك سجل
لهذا الامر وعلى حد علمي لا اعتقد ان
الرئيس ترامب قد حصل على اي مستندات قد
رفعت عنها سريه
وكان قد احتفظ بها رغم انه لم يعد رئيسا
وعند ذلك الحين لم يعد يمتلك صلاحيه
لابقائها
طيب دكتور ريتشارد حتى نفهم اكثر هل يحق
للرئيس الامريكي ان يقرر متى يشاء وكيف ما
يشاء ان يرفع السريه عن وثائق تصنف بانها
سريه وسريه للغايه وهو في فتره ولايته
وبالتالي بامكاني ان يحتفظ بها بعد
مغادرته المنصب وترك البيت الابيض
له الصلاحيه في رفع سريه عن المستندات
ومن غير الواضح انه
قد اتبع
هذا هذا تلك القاعده عندما ترك البيت
الابيض لكن المشكله ان قانون التجسس لعام
1970 كان قد صدر قبل ان يكون هناك اي
تصنيفا للمستندات فاذا
فتتم الاشاره الان الى مساله التي تصنيف
الذي كان مطبقا انذاك
وقد لا يكون هذا امرا واردا لاثبات وجود
اي انتهاك بحق ترامب لذلك القانون
طيب ابقى معنا الان مستمرون معكم ونتحدث
ايضا عن شخصيه الان تكرر ذكرها في موضوع
المحاكمه انه جاك سميث المدعي الفيدرالي
الذي اعلن عن لائحه التهم الموجهه لرئيس
سابق دونالد ترامب فمن هو متابع في هذا
التقرير
[موسيقى]
اذا استاذ حسين اعود اليك وكنا عرضنا هذا
التقرير حول الشخصيه التي تكرر ذكرها جاكس
ميث المدعي الفيدرالي
هل من كلمات اي تعليق حول جاك سميث من
قبلكم
لا اعتقد ان هناك
شكوك من من الحزبين يعني بشخصيات الرجل
هناك عدد كبير من العاملين في الحقل
القانوني في الادعاء والدفاع والقضاء ومن
المحلفين ممن لا عباره عليهم يعني لا توجد
اسباب واضحه طبعا من حين الى اخر كان
الرئيس ترامب يحاول الطعم بشخصيات في يعني
في المؤسسات
الشرطه الفيدراليه وما شابه وبعض هؤلاء
ثبت انهم يعني قاموا باخطاء او تجاوزات
القانون ولكن هذا لا يعني انه كل شخص
يمارس اي اي قانون
ويتهم ويوجه لائحه الاتهام انه هناك مشكله
في هذا الشخص نفسه
لا شخصيه الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب هو دخل الى الرئاسه من خارج عالم
السياسه نتحدث عن بزنس مان اليوم يعني
بالمنطق هل يمكن لشخص مثلا بزنس مان
كادونال ترامب وان يفكر بذكاء ان يقع في
هكذا ورطه ان يكون بهكذا سذاجه لكي يورط
نفسه في هكذا تهم قانونيه تدين وقد تجرم
وقد تذهب به الى السجن مدى الحياه
هو يعني رجل الاعمال السيف ذو حدين للرئيس
ترامب من ناحيه هو لا تحكمه التزامات
المؤسسه الحاكمه من الحزبين ولكن من ناحيه
ثانيه تنقصه خبره التدرج في الحكم خبره
معرفه القوانين ثم اننا لو نظرنا الى
تجربه السيد ترامب اثناء يعني حياته كرجل
اعمال
بلاقينا لانه هو كان في يعني متاعب دائما
مع القانون يوما كان يعلن افلاسه يوما
كانوا يرفعون دعاوى عليه يوما كان هو يرفع
دعائه على المصارف وهكذا دواليك
كان يتعامل دائما بخفه مع القوانين لانه
في عالم الاعمال يعني عالم اعمال ينظر ان
يكون جنائيا ولكن هذه الخفه لا يمكن ان
ينقلها معه الى البيت الابيض هذه وثائق
عاليه السريه وهو لو كان اعلن رفع السريه
عنها بتصنيفها
لططر الى اعلان هذا يعني رفع السريه لا
يمكن ان يكون بسريه يعني لا يرفع السريه
وياخذ الاوراق معه ويرفع السريه وتصبح هذه
الوثائق متاحه لكل المواطنين الامريكيين
لانه طبعا الرئيس السابق يصبح مواطن يصبح
مواطنا عاديا فاذا كان يحق لي ويحق لاي
مواطن امريكي النظر الى هذه الوثائق ولاحق
للرئيس وحده انه ياخذ الوثائق معه الى الى
بيته هذه هي الاشكاليه اعتقد انه لانه هو
ياتي من عالم الاعمال ولم يتدرج في
الحكومه في مسائل القانون والسياسه في
العاصمه الامريكيه اعتقد انها هي التي
اثارت المتاعب التي يواجهها الرئيس السابق
اليوم استاذ حسين كانت التحليلات في
المحاكمه السابقه في نيويورك عن كيف
سيستفيد ترامب من محاكمه نيويورك حينها
للمضي قدما في الترشح للحزب الجمهوري وحتى
لانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله وايضا جمع
وحصد الملايين فيما يتعلق بحملته
الانتخابيه اليوم هل الوضع مختلف ام ان
المساله مشابهه بان الرئيس يمكن مش اي شكل
من الاشكال ان يستفيد نوعا ما من هذه
المحاكمه بان ترامب عاد الى الواجهه اسمه
متكرر ماذا
لا شك ان الوضع مختلف تماما
المحاكمه الاولى كانت اولا على صعيد ولايه
وكانت محاكمه استعراضيه وكان هناك اجماع
انه الادعاء ضعيف ضده للرئيس وانه الادعاء
لا
عواقب جنائيه له يعني لو حصلت مخالفه
لقوانين الانتخاب يمكن تعويض عن هذه
المخالفه بغرامات مثلا هذه المره الادعاء
اكثر جديه بكثير يتعلق بالامن القومي
الامريكي الادعاء ياتي من وزاره العدل
الفيدراليه اذا هو يعني ليس محصورا بولايه
واحده ويبدو انه من قاموا بنسج هذه
اللائحه الاتهاميه هذه المره عملوا يعني
بالصبر وبجهد وبكد لانه استغرقوا وقتا
طويلا لو تذكرين انه هذه موضوع الوثائق
يعني
سمعنا به منذ شهور عديده ومنذ ذلك لم نعرف
ماذا يحصل فاذا كان هناك عمليه يتم
التحضير اليها بهدوء وسبب الهدوء هو حتى
تكون لائحه الاتهاميه يعني تامه حتى تقنع
المحلفين وتقنع القاضي بانه هذه قضيه لا
يمكن
ترامب الخروج منها على غرار القضيه
الماضيه في نيويورك طيب هل هذا يرفع حظوظ
منافسيه كانت الغلبه له اما في استطلاعات
الراي او حتى من خلال التصريحات الصادره
عنه اليوم كيف سيتلقف منافسي الرئيس
دونالد ترامب فيما يتعلق بالحزب الجمهوري
والترشيحات في الاشهر المقبله
طبعا هذا يعني هذا السؤال
ممتاز ولكن هناك المشكله انه لا يعني لا
نعرف لا يمكن تقدير كيف ستكون رده فعل
قاعده الحزب الجمهوري وبعد ذلك كيف يؤثر
ذلك على الانتخابات العامه ربما تلتصق
قاعده الحزب الجمهوري
تتمسك به وتعيد يعني ترشيحه باسم الحزب
ولكن هذا التمسك قد يؤدي الى دفع الحزب
الى اقصى اليمين وهو ما يبعد الناخبين
المستقلين والوسططيين عن الحزب الجمهوري
ويدفع بهم الى الحزب الديمقراطي فهناك
اكثر من عامل ولا اعتقد انه هذه يعني
المحاكمه وحدها ستقرر ولكن في حال تمسكت
القاعده جمهوريه بالسيد التام على الرغم
من انه يعني بدا ان هناك تجاوزات صحيحه
وانه ان قام القضاء باي ادانه فعليه للسيد
ترامب اعتقد ذلك
سيثير ازمه للحزب الجمهوري بكامله حتى لو
لم يستطع اي من المنافسين يعني ان يتجاوز
ولكن انت تجاوز المنافسون الجمهوريين انت
تجاوزوا ترامب اعتقد انه وقت هذاك تصبح
الحظوظ متساويه بين الحسبين في اعاده او
في يعني الانتخابات الرئاسيه بين الاثنين
العام المقبل استاذ حسين ابقى معنا وجديد
المعلومات والاخبار المتعلقه بمحاكمه
ترامب من سيدافع عن ترامب في المحكمه
ويواجه كل هذه الاتهامات التي تثقل كاهل
رئيس السابق والمرشح الجمهوري لرئاسيات 20
24 طبعا هناك فريق قانوني كامل للدفاع
ترامب لكن عضوا رئيسيا في هذا الفريق جذب
الانتباه اكثر من غيره وهو المحامي توب
بلانش والذي يمثل ترامب ايضا في قضيه
نيويورك الجنائيه المتعلقه بدفع اموال
مزعومه في عام 2016
لممثله الافلام الاباحيه السوعمي دانيلز
حيث يقود الفريق القانوني للرئيس السابق
من هو هذا الخبير القانوني نتابع في
التقرير
[موسيقى]
اخر الاخبار اذا رئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
يدخل قاعه المحكمه في ميامي ليمثل بقضيه
الوثائق السريه هذه هي اخر المعلومات
والتفاصيل هذا هو العاجل الذي ترونه اسفل
الشاشه امامكم التي الذي ياتينا من
فلوريدا ومن المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي
بالتحديد وما زلنا ننقل لكم هذه الصور حيث
سار الموكب من منتجع ترامب حيث يمكث في
ولايته في في ولايه فلوريدا وبالتحديد في
مالاجو وكان اتجه ونقلنا ايضا لكم هذه
الصوره من خلف السياره وحيث يتجمع انصار
ومؤيد الرئيس السابق في محيط
المحكمه نذهب مره اخرى الى دكتور ريتشارد
بيرس والساده القانون في جامعه جورج
واشنطن دكتور فيما يتعلق والذي يمكن ان
يفعله في قضيه دونالد ترامب بالوثائق
المسربه في المحكمه
دكتور هل تسمعني
[موسيقى]
لكن هل لك ان تعيدي اسم المحامي طيب كنا
عرضنا التقرير فيما يتعلق اليوم ما الذي
يمكن ان يفعله في سير المحكمه بالنظر الى
شخصيتي هذا الشخص
لا اعلم
فانا لست على معرفه بهذا المحامي ولست
متاكدا ما هو الدور الذي قد يلعبه
طيب دكتور ريتشارد كفر الحديث في الاونه
الاخيره ومن بين تصريحات على لسان الرئيس
السابق ترامب بانه حتى لو سجن وكان خلف
القطبان سيستمر في
المضي ايضا ترشحه للرئاسه فبالتالي اليوم
اذا ما تحدثنا ايضا قانونيا هل يحق لشخص
فقط نريد ان نشير لهذا العاجل قبل ان
نستكمل الاسئله اذا العاج الذي ترونه
امامكم قاضي الصلح جونسون غودمان يتلو
لائحه اتهامات ترامب في محكمه مياضي كنا
ذكرنا لكم قبل دقائق من الان بان الرئيس
سابق دونالد ترامب دخل قاعه المحكمه في
ميامي ليمتل بقضيه الوثائق السريه وهذا هو
قاضي صلح جون جودمان يتلو لائحه اتهامات
ترامب في محكمه ميامي وطبعا نتحدث عن
لائحه الاتهام التي تتضمن 37 تهمه جنائيه
كشف عنها الادعاء احدى وثلاثون تهمه منها
تخص الاحتفاظ المتعمد بوثائق تتعلق بالامن
القومي وهو ما يخالف قانونا بشان التجسس
يحضر الاحتفاظ باسرار الدوله في اماكن غير
مرخصه ايضا شملت لائحه الاتهام والتي
يتلوها الان قاده صلح جونثون في محكمه
ميامي المحكمه الفيدراليه تشمل ايضا
بالاضافه الى التهمه التي ذكرناها ثلاث
تهم ايضا بحجب او اخفاء مستندات في تحقيق
فيدرالي الى جانب تهمتين تتعلقان
بالبيانات الكاذبه وتهمه تخص عرقله سير
العداله هذه اذا لائحه الالتهاب التي
يتلوها الان قاضي صلح جونيث في محكمه
ميامي حيث سير محاكمه رئيس سابق دونالد
ترامبلادي وصل الى المحكمه قبل حوالي ساعه
من الان ليمثل في هذا اليوم طبعا هذا
اليوم التاريخي
والامطار كلها صوب اذا ميامي وصوب هذه
المحكمه عود مره اخرى الى دكتور ريتشارد
نيكسون
استاذ القانون في جامعه جورج تاون دكتور
ريتشرد يعني معك في هذه التغطيه والان
فيما يتعلق بترشيح الرئيس في حال مثلا تم
سجنه كان هناك حديث وحتى من الرئيس السابق
نفسه بانه سيستمر وسيمضي في حملتي
الانتخابيه حتى ولو كان خلف القطبان هل
القانونيا يحق لشخص ايضا ان يترشح وهو خلف
القضبان
من ناحيه قانونيه بمقدوره بذلك حتى لو تمت
ازالته
وتم سجنه
وبمجرد تنصيبه رئيسا مجددا
فما من قانوني
[موسيقى]
لترشحه للرئاسه اذن من ناحيه قانونيه
بمقدوره فعل ذلك
دكتور ريتشارد بيرس استاذ القانون في
جامعه جورج واشنطن وايضا نشكر ضيفنا من
واشنطن حسين عبد الحسين الباحث في مؤسسه
الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات شكرا جزيلا لكما
اذا اختيار المحامين هو تجميع فريق الدفاع
مهمه اولى هرع مستشار الرئيس الامريكي
السابق لاتمام قبل مثوله امام المحكمه لكن
التحدي الاكبر يتمثل بكيفيه ضاحظ
الاتهامات في قضيه جنائيه قد تكون
خياراتهم محدوده فيها فالحجج قد تبدا
باستخدام نظام القانوني لتاخير القضيه اي
التاكيد على حق ترامب في اخذ الوثائق من
البيت الابيض بحجه انه رفع السريه عنها
قبل مغادرته لمنصبه السيرك السياسي قد
يتواصل مع اتهام الادعاء بسوء السلوك
ومحاوله الاثبات ان عمليه هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى التي ادت الى لائحه الاتهام شابتها
عيوب فتصوير ترامب لنفسه كضحيه للمدعين
الفيدراليين ضمن الخيارات اي ما سمي
بالمحاكمه الانتقائيه خبراء قانونيون
رجحوا ان محامي ترامب ومحاميه سيزعمون ان
التهم غير عادله ولم يتعرض لها سياسيون
اخرون كانوا واجهوا تحقيقا بسب تعاملهم مع
المستندات السريه وبينهم هيلر كلينتون
فالمدع الفيدرالي السابق واستاذ القانون
في جامعه جيوب سامويل بويل كان وصف معركه
ترامب بشاقه واي محاوله لاجراء مثل هذه
المقارنات هي خاسره تماما فقضيه ترامب
تضمنت عددا هائلا من الوثائق السريه وادله
مهمه على عرقله لم تحدث مع سياسيين اخرين
كما تقول نيويورك تايمز غير ان مراقبين
اكدوا ان امكانيه تاخير القضيه بشكل كاف
الى ما بعد الانتخابات حتى لو لم تنجح اي
من هذه المحاولات لعرقله التهم وان فاز
ترامب فيطلب بنفسه تخلي المدعي العام عن
هذه القضيه او العفو عنه
[موسيقى]
قانون عمره 100 عام استخدم لمحاكمه
الجواسيس والمسربين ويشكل خطرا قانونيا
كبيرا على رئيس الامريكي السابق قضايا
سابقه عده لقانون التجسس تشكل علامات
تحذير ترامب احدثها ما حصل مع الكولونيل
روبرت بيرشن الذي تهم باساءه التعامل مع
وثائق السريه فضابط المخابرات تحمل
المسؤوليه كامله وتعاون مع المحققين على
عكس ترامب فانخفضت عقوبته وحكم بالسجن
لمده ثلاث سنوات وفقا ما ذكرته نيويورك
تايمز فمنذ خمس سنوات تم تسجيل حوالي
اثنتي عشره محاكمه جنائيه لاشخاص يحتفظون
بمعلومات سريه او معلومات دفاع وطني وفقا
لوزاره العدل في العديد من هذه القضايا
تلقى المتهمون احكاما طويله بالسجن بينهم
الموظفان السابقان في وكاله الامن القومي
هارولد مارتن
وحكم بالسجن سنوات وخمس سنوات تباعا بعدها
كما حكم في ابريل الماضي على رقيب سابق في
القوات الخاصه بالسجن سبع سنوات وثلاثه
اشهر بسبب الاحتفاظ بمعلومات سريه
بالاضافه الى جرائم اخرى اذكروا انها
المره الاولى التي يتم فيها اتهام رئيس
سابق ارتكاب انتهاك جنائيا فيدرالي لكن
كانت هناك حالات سابقه لملاحقات
لسياسيين تضمنت مزاعم جنح وليست جنايه
كانت تتعلق بانتهاك قانون التجسس اذا
ترامب يمثل امام قاضي محكمه ميامي بقضيه
الوثائق السريه التغطيه مستمره على شاشه
العربيه معكم بعد قليل طاهر وراويه في 360
مساء الخير مساء النور ونخصصها لهذه
المحاكمه التي بدات للنادين شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات